so thank you very much for for showing
up my name is Noah Morris I'm an
ecologist at an organization called eco
health alliance that's based locally
here in New York and works
internationally in infectious diseases
and wildlife conservation globally we
work in Southeast Asia West Africa South
Africa South Asia South America as well
and it's an interdisciplinary
organization of field veterinarians data
scientists biologists genomicists bio in
from missions policy experts public
public health experts medical
anthropologists and we do a lot of
complex and inter-institutional work on
these issues and the but the tools that
we use sort of need to be sustainable
and for that reason I also wear another
hat with another organization called are
open SCI and are open SCI is an
organization a developer collective that
builds technical and community
infrastructure for open reproducible
science and we work primarily in the our
language not Python which makes me a bit
of an odd man out here but what we try
to do is create a space that allows
researcher developers to build the tools
they need and share those tools across
lab groups and build the infrastructure
to help people share data across
different types of scientific projects
and we try to fill holes that
researchers have in the data management
and reproducibility cycle and recently
we've split off and spawned a new
organization with a whole new set of
developers called pi open SCI that does
much of the same thing they launched at
Syfy last year and they've begun doing
similar work to us as well and we're
working in really close partnership and
so I'm glad to be able to talk about the
work that they're starting as well the
big thing that we do in our up inside
that consumes the day-to-day of our time
and sort of our whole developer
community
is the development of the lots and lots
of field-specific packages for managing
certain types of data in certain types
of data repositories and managing the
whole data management lifecycle and we
produce lots of things dealing with
entomological data archaeological data
earth sciences data all sorts of things
we have work from historians look
working the natural text processing to
sort of base tools having to do with you
know real problems in basic data munging
issues of working between formats and
such so we produce a lot of these is a
big community of authors and at a
certain point as this expand and
expanded and as our author base expanded
we needed to figure out how to validate
and quality control all of the things
entering our repository in our
collection and being primarily academic
researchers we come out of a tradition
of sort of academic peer review an
academic peer review is a little bit
different from what may be common in
sort of an end software engineering
space which is often sort of production
code review so when one reviews code in
a production software development
environment it tends to be a granular
process where people submit patches or
pull requests to repositories often
what's being reviewed is narrow in scope
you know you've got one function you've
got one change you've got one or a
refactor and there's a few specific
things that you're looking at within
that and the people are reviewing that
are generally ones project collaborators
people who know you well and people who
know the project well so they can
understand the context that it goes in
and the reason one does this is
primarily quality control because you
want to make sure that you're not
introducing bugs or introducing
conflicts into your program but those of
us who come out of an academic research
tradition tend to be more familiar with
the idea of academic peer review which
is a different social structure
essentially so when one reviews
something in an academic peer review
environment it's generally so
a project-wide review one is usually
submitting a manuscript that may
represent years and years and work of a
group and the reviewers have a mandate
to review everything in it from methods
to theory to data to the quality of the
presentation and generally the people
are reviewing it our peers in your field
who are external to your group often
anonymous peers often mediated by some
sort of editorial process and the
purpose is to measure quality to you
know remove problematic components of
your work to improve its quality but
also to confer the legitimacy of other
people in your fields to give a stamp of
approval so that when it goes out into
the world other people can feel that
it's validated so we decided to draw on
components of both of these because many
of our developers come from this
academic tradition but also many of them
work in small to single person groups
they're often the only developer within
an otherwise research group and the idea
of having external peers review their
code appeal to a great many of them
because they wanted to reach out to the
broader community for both for both
wisdom and also that validity you can
also sort of think of this as a spectrum
where on one side you have very frequent
iteration within a team that has very
high familiarity with a project and at
the most extreme end that's basically
pair programming when you have two
people or more sitting side-by-side
working on the code together to the
other extreme where you have this
project level peer review and then in
the middle you may have sort of this
patch or pull request approach so why
did we go about this peer review and
what are we able to do it do with it
well there are three goals we wanted in
the design of the system one is to drive
adoption of best practices and standards
again our pool of data scientists and
developers often do this as a secondary
job as part of their main sort of a
research goal so
they're not necessarily trained in
software engineering and therefore don't
necessarily have the opportunity to
learn all of the engineering best
practices for when they produce their
code secondly we wanted to increase
quality in the long tail of applications
because there's lots of specialty code
that's created for all these
domain-specific applications and we want
to make sure that it had the eyes on it
that you also get for big open source
software practices and I wanted to
create a community practice out of this
we have lots of isolated researchers
working in groups all over around the
world we wanted to build a community
where they can share knowledge with each
other so the first of this is driving
the adoption of best practices and
standards across the group and one of
the real surprises that we found in this
is that people whose code is reviewed
learn a lot from their reviewers but the
reviewers learn a lot from people's
whose code their review it's often said
that one of the things you should do as
you are learning to code as you are
learning software engineering is to read
a lot of code in addition to writing it
but often we don't really have the time
to do that so reviewing other people's
code gives you the opportunity to see
other ways that people implement things
to see other tools that people that
people use other patterns of software
engineering and we occasionally survey
our authors and reviewers to ask them
how the process in going and what and
what they get out of it and we've gotten
lots of comments from both our authors
and reviewers of how much they learn by
participating in a peer-review process
so these are some quotes from a survey
that we completed their review process
taught me a lot about different tools
available from making my code more
robust and resilient to changes so that
means we're driving these best practices
into the author base or another I learn
a lot from closely reading other
people's code and is hard to do so when
I'm not forced to reviews not forced to
review so closely they're really it
really is kind of rare especially for
part-time developers to have the time to
read code line by line to learn new
things
so the other thing we wanted to do was
increase the quality in this long tail
of applications like almost any creative
production um in software packages
beat'em the our ecosystem in the Python
ecosystem or any other creative works
there's a lot of inequality not
necessarily in a bad sense but in the
number of eyes that go on to a package
so this is a rank rank graph of the
number of downloads that packages within
the our ecosystem
get downloaded every month and there are
these all the way on your left here
there's a few of them that everyone uses
the equivalent of the pandas and the
numpy is and millions of people download
this and millions or hundreds of
thousands people are using them there is
a big user base and there's a big
developer base of people who can submit
patches and bug reports and file issues
and there's a lot of eyes on that type
of code but most software that's written
and most software that's published
doesn't have that huge base and so most
people who are writing things don't have
the opportunity for people to look at
their code and find those issues and
help improve it an example I like to put
up we have many of them in our
collection is something that I'm sure no
one in this room has seen and when I
talk in our conference no one has seen
either but one little package which is a
client to the South Florida Water
Management District right like this is
not something that anyone is going to
use if they're not in the community of
perhaps at best a hundred people who
need to do data analysis on flows of
water within the Everglades but flows of
water within the Everglades are a really
important thing affecting millions of
people in South Florida and becoming a
bigger issue every day about how water
is allocated whether it's preventing
flooding whether it's making sure
farmers have the right amount of water
on their land so it's really important
that this data is analyzed in a robust
way
that the policymakers who are getting
information from people who are
analyzing it are getting bug free
reports and so this is something that's
in our collection and someone who
published this wouldn't have the
opportunity to have a lot of people
submitting bug reports and by putting it
through peer review it's something that
we can increase the quality of but the
other thing that we can do through peer
review is build a community of practice
amongst a big constellation of disparate
researchers so among the decisions we
made even though we were pushing sort of
an academic peer review model where you
have external reviewers is we didn't
anonymize it we made it non anonymous in
both directions and so reviewers and
authors are able to interact directly
rather than just be mediated through an
editor and you have lots of this direct
dialogue where are people who will have
a conversation in github issues are able
to - in addition to just critiquing
their package giving you know opinions
about documentation testing and they get
to know each other this way and what
happens is that reviewers and authors
can go on to become collaborators so
this is something that people like a lot
has anyone here have been involved in
sort of the academic manuscript peer
review process in their work right a
couple of people a few people here and I
would say it always shocks me how much
people like this because even in the
absolute best editing and publication
process I don't know any author who's
really really excited to see what their
reviewers are gonna tell them right like
you'd read it right because there's a
you know it's built to convey critiques
to you and you don't have interaction
with these people but when you build up
when you have sort of a community driven
process like this people end up being
really eager to see the type of feedback
they get most people who are data
scientists within research groups don't
have the opportunity to interact with
this constellation of people
and sir able to not only have a really
great interaction you're able to create
a process where people are Eagle eager
to continue to interact with their
critics so those things of standards
applications and community of practice
within an organization within a team
that one is building basically comes
down to be having training having
quality control and having a team
building process and so we build this in
a large open source community but within
within an analytics team across
especially multiple analytics teams
within an organization incorporating
processes like this can help you drive
all of these things within an
organization so one of the questions is
how do you do this type of review well
both as an organizer or as an individual
reviewer and that's something that we've
been slowly trying to understand an
extract wisdom from our reviewers
because it's often one of these you know
a good one when you see it type things
which is difficult to understand what
the process of a good reviewer is but
it's something we're just beginning to
pull out and understand and so far these
are some of the highlights we think of
the good practices when one is building
a review system or doing a review now
that we've had something like 250
packages in the are open size system go
through this and I think six in the pie
open sigh that just started this year so
the first important thing when one is
doing review is to have a shared common
set of standards and it can be daunting
trying to set standards for one's own
work but the important thing is to start
small on the important things and then
steal most of them because there are a
lot of good standards out there that
different groups have developed often
for similar goal
that you might have so both are open
sigh and pie opens I have developer and
reviewer guides that set standards for
what we want in packages and what we
recommend for authors to do and what we
recommend that reviewers step through so
we have this book our open side packages
development maintenance in peer review
piyo pants I recently started developing
their own based off of us they're both
available on the web but these of course
are derived from a lot of work that
others have done in the past in terms of
sort of coder view in a laboratory
scientific context one of the original
good sources was the Mozilla science lab
so Mozilla had a specific scientific
processes group within the Mizzou
Mozilla Foundation and they sort of set
these high-level review goals for
looking at code what do you ask of
packaged when you're sort of thinking at
the high level across lots of different
things so some of those were are the
functions as simple as possible or do
you have a lot of complexity packed into
individual functions that's tough to
understand on an individual basis is the
code efficient is it doing things is it
performing as well as it should is the
usage of what each function of unit code
clear and how a vege case has been
considered these are like not you know
you know great revelations but when one
is going through a code base you want to
have this sort of high level standards
of things that you want reviewers to
think about as you're walking through
them because you're also going to as you
go through this process and develop
something as a team accumulate a whole
bunch of very small low-level standards
and we were just having a debate about
one of these on our view those happening
over in PI open SCI with the packages
we've run and are open sized for a
number of years and we realized that in
our people don't generally write
command-line tools but in Python people
do and suddenly what gets printed to
standard out and what gets printed to
standard error becomes important for how
things get put into a pipeline and so
Neela's we have to come to an agreement
as to what do we print and standard out
and what do we print in standard error
and we want to have that thing so that
every viewer can check it off as it as
in the checkbox that things are
occurring correctly so you're gonna have
accumulate lots of these little things
in style guides and interaction guides
as your team gains experience but
there's lots of sources for all of these
types of style guides and they can occur
at all sorts of levels so on the top
right there's a journal called the
Journal of open source software and
that's any applicant if ik application
any any language journal and they have
lots of high level standards that you
can pull from so the general checks
about licensing and version and
authorship and attribution and how does
the entire there is the installation
process work how does the functionality
work high level things then there's
another group bioconductor bioconductor
developed scientific software specific
to genomics and genetics they have a
large repository also author contributed
and they're very interested in genomic
data structures because they want to
make sure that all the tools that people
contribute and everything that people
use use the same in-memory structure for
genomic data as you can pass that data
around to different types of to
different types of tools you know in the
Python world you have a lot more of
these large omnibus packages like sci-fi
or matplotlib that contain a lot of
different functionality and so those
groups will have style guides of what
your patch should look like and then
when you get away from the software
tools and into the analysis space there
are style guides for what a notebook or
an analysis should look like I really
like this one this is a group called a
recon recon does epidemiological
analysis as a group together with
Doctors Without Borders and the World
Health Organization so they're a group
of data scientists that deploy what's
called a a deployment cell which comes
in the World Health Organization
emergency disease outbreak zone so the
bunch of them in the DRC right now
dealing with the Ebola epidemic and
their job is to gather clean and
distribute data as needed for all of the
different doctors and policy makers and
first responders so they have the right
information so they have a set of style
standards for the scripts that they
write to make sure that everything it
adheres and can be understood when the
cells turn over to a new group of data
scientists and when they bring new
locals on that they train so you can
have stands of the standards of this
sort for with all types of different
priorities and at all different scales
you know another thing that's in not in
any of these but is a common set four
types of code audits is security
standards is your you know is your
package meet security standards meet
security audits if that's an important
part of what your group's work is that's
something you'd include so first we need
a set of standards the next thing that
we found is really important is to
automate as many of those standards as
possible code review is a hard thing to
do especially one does external peer
review it can be hundreds or thousands
of lines of code that people need to
read so you want to minimize the things
that don't have to be done by the
reviewers so you can maximize the time
they spend on the things that need a
human brain there are a lot of things
that can be done via automatic checking
and obviously this is different by using
the in the language and the frameworks
that you use but parts are all of the
types of things you want to check in the
package can be done automatically so
maybe it's the functionality that the
functions are doing what they say they
are that they are implementing the
algorithm they say you can use linters
to check style and readability you can
check you can check the the interface or
tests or automate whether there's
documentation for different things in
the our ecosystem as there is in the
Python ecosystem there are packages that
cover lots of these things there's
standard checkers that are associate
with different repositories you can have
a package testing framework you can test
completeness by checking how much of the
code is coverage by testing if you're
doing documentation there's spell
checking which is not something that
people have to do on their own you can
have a linter which looks at your code
style and your indentation and your
structure and that can automatically
report we have a thing that we use
called good practice that looks for anti
patterns of things that we found are
likely numerical errors and it hunts for
those and looks and measures the code
complexity to make sure functions aren't
too complex and it gives us things
reports like this when you run it on a
package that tells us ok what's the unit
testing coverage you know here's
something that you have in your metadata
that tends to go out of date here's a
style issue that's that we find is
confusing for people we like that
code lines aren't too long so they're
easier to read and we see this anti
pattern in your code that tends to cause
the tends to cause errors in edge cases
and so as much as you can automate in a
peer-review process be it something that
you ask authors to do on their own work
or you do on work that is submitted that
supports your that supports your
reviewers and minimizing what they have
to do and also giving them guides as to
what to look at because they can see
where the flags are and even if they're
not flags that say this is totally wrong
there may be a flag saying this is where
you should check something out and of
course those kinds of things can be run
not just on your computer and the
authors but we have but on continuous
integration systems so you can submit to
those and get a report
we find the first thing that our viewers
should do is run what the developer
expects them to most packages will have
a readme a set of documentation a
tutorial which will say here's a guide
here's how to use this here's how you
run this on a set of data and the first
thing you want a reviewer to do is do
what the author expects and walk through
walks through that you often find a
bunch of errors often associated with
changes to versioning as the
documentation and the package fall out
of sync in some way and having to do
with cross-platform compatibility and
environment issues that the author may
not not have considered and so it's an
example of that in our packages we have
the concept of a vignette a vignette is
really is an extended narrative
documentation of literate code and it's
something you can walk through and you
can run into issues just walking reading
the code that they expect to run well
and may run well on the author's
computer but then doesn't run well on
yours and so we tend to find the first
thing you need to do is run that
developer workflow but once you've run
that developer workflow or your viewer
has you want to break that workflow by
taking what the author expects you to do
and shifting it to another context so
that might be bringing your own data or
your own problem it's actually a big
challenge one has in finding reviewers
is that you want to find people who are
likely to have some sort of opportunity
to do this they may be in a similar
field they have access to a data set
they might have a set of problems that a
package would solve and they have some
new application to set it on so this is
a common thing so on the left there was
a package that was a Flickr client and
and image recognition package that the
idea was the author said okay I'm going
to try to find out where snakes did
exist in the UK and I want to like
search for snake images within a lot
long and this is what I did
and this is what I tried and here are
the errors that I ran into along the way
because there was some difference in the
data structure that I pulled down
compared to the one of the examples
these other ones are other examples
where we were doing natural language
processing and there's a natural
language process package and we both
this bottom one is me and David this
this other of you were both had a big
corpus of documents so the package came
with a corpus of documents to test on
but we found edge cases in our documents
there were not in theirs what happens
when you have zero length document what
happens when you're running in a
different type in an environment where
you don't get the performance you expect
so you do the authors version and then
you do your own version and you can find
those edge cases but when you look at
the source code itself once one's sort
of through just sort of running through
the exercises and you're looking line by
line that's where things can get really
challenging and the thing that we find
in the best reviews is that people find
some way to make a map of the source
code sometimes that map is available
because the authors describe things in
the documentation have some sort of
developer documentation this
specifically lays out classes and file
structure and all sorts of things but
that's actually pretty rare so you have
to find some sort of structure through
which to go through the code that's not
just paging through file by file so
maybe there's a document organization in
which you're going to follow the
documents and then go to those classes
and the source code lines associate in
which each part of the documents maybe
there's a function hierarchy or an
object hierarchy or a test hierarchy but
all the time you do need to find that
map and there are a lot of different
ways to do that so sometimes it's in
test coverage so the test coverage
framework we use will report test
coverage file by file and it'll show
whether is test covered and where there
is not and where there's not test
coverage are often good points of entry
that's like a way to dive into the code
and see okay what is going on in the
places that is not tested and how do I
let's look at the source there and
understand where that's the case one of
the things I like to use is there's a
counting lines of code package I think
this has been ported all over the place
who was there I think it's like written
it's like a perl script that's existed
forever and has been you know wrapped in
Python and wrapped in our clock which
counts lines of code and it's a way of
discovering especially in the our world
but also in Python you have a lot of
polyglot packages because there's a lot
of bindings across to other things and
so running something like this helps you
find out okay well there's some bits of
there's some bits of JavaScript in this
case some bits of Lua in this package
which give me an idea of something that
I need to look into and understand why
that is but most code frameworks have
some sort of static or dynamic code
analysis tools are is a very functional
language functions rather than objects
tend to be the fundamental building
blocks of most packages and because
they're nested one can generate a
function Network and so this is some
work by Joyce Robbins who's a professor
here in NYC at Columbia who's worked
with us and it's an interactive tool
that does that type of static static
code analysis to understand what is the
package structure what are the exported
functions that one is that one uses what
are the internal functions that they
call and a map like this is a good way
to start in which one can go from okay
let's look at these exported functions
and then dive in what are the important
internal functionalities that they
depend on and let's look at the code in
that structure and often you end up
finding there's some you know central
functionality and that's what you need
to spend your time looking at the source
in the end one then needs to sort of
follow that map through the source code
line by line and you know this is where
the this is has always been the what
exactly do people do in this case that
makes them good or viewers and one of
the things we find is people tend to
keep their you know you keep your
standards guide handy as you do that and
use that as alongside as you're reading
the code but two separate things that
are sort of big problems film little
notes and the little notes and typos and
ideas for change and you track that and
then the other thing we find is very
important for people to do in order to
have sort of a robust review ecosystem
is to make sure they're noting not where
they see potential sources of error or
things that could be fixed but good
parts of the implementation that they
want to repeat and they want to use for
themselves and then also communicate
that back to the author and then the
other thing that we find tends to be
really helpful is where they have see
patterns or analogues to other work that
you know see when you see oh you're
doing this I've seen this in this other
package they did it in this other
framework
maybe that's useful and then people put
that together in what we have as these
package reviews and so the package
reviews that we set have checkboxes for
things that you're supposed to look at
and then this extended narrative which
is again built off of sort of the
tradition of the academic review of
large manuscripts where we start from
the big ideas of like what's important
structurally right and then we have
minor notes we found this missing the
test we found this typo in the
documentation at the SLO level we find
this edge case or this thing in the
Diagnostics that is important to look at
and of course the most important thing
is that you highlight the good parts of
what's working really well because
that's important for building that
community aspect and you're nice when
you do it it is
impossible to find everything you know a
peer review is only so good and so we
tend to try to find people who have
mixed expertise we have reviewers who
are in particularly knowledgeable about
say the statistical method that is being
implemented and another one who's
particularly knowledgeable about the
sort of code framework that's being used
so people can cover what they can they
try to cover every line code they can
but it's most important that they bring
their particular expertise and then it's
the community aspect that helps people
level up in quality so at this point
we've been doing this for five years
we've been doing it we've done it for
two hundred and so packages it's
extended from initially just working on
things related to metadata management
data exchange and visualizations and
we're extending more and more we have a
new grant from the sloan Foundation to
establish standards for statistical
validation and correctness and
algorithms that were very excited to be
starting up soon but we think it's a
process that's useful at many scales and
while we are building this large
community across a particular sort of
academic and research view it's
something that is useful sort of across
large open-source communities small ones
and individual enterprises where as
you're a developer or a researcher or a
team you want people to get better
training to improve their work improve
the quality of the code base that you
have and build a community or a team in
that so you can produce awesome work and
so I'd like to just sort of convey that
we think this has a lot of value and we
want people to participate so with that
thank you and I'll just highlight on the
left here is the editorial team for our
open SCI on the right here as the
editorial for Team for pie open SCI
which includes a number of the
developers for Jupiter and SCI PI and
Conda all numb focused projects involved
in this
and if you're interested in
participating in this process you just
can visit us at our open side org or PI
open side org in which case you'll
really have the opportunity to get on
the ground floor as this one's just
taking off and establishing those
standards so thank you very much any
questions yeah well well it tends to be
so most of our authors are sort of
developer researchers who have developed
a method or have to deal with a
particular workflow that deals with a
specific field of data so they're a
bunch of people who do cell flow
cytometry which is a certain type of
sort of biomedical measurement and the
data comes out of certain instruments
and they need to produce certain types
of summary data from that then you
manipulate it in certain ways and it
needs to go to a particular archive with
particular metadata and those things had
traditionally been done manually and
they've built that workflow often for
their particular lab environment and
they want to generalize it in a way that
is good for people in their field to use
all around but they've been working on
that problem particular and don't
necessarily have sort of a little of the
broader software engineering perspective
and so that's what most of these are
they tend to be you know something that
is extremely specific that is trying to
become more general and more robust and
more maintainable in the long term and
what we try to do is bring the practices
to those researchers of the day so that
they're able to build those maintainable
packages from what are usually
originally just a collection of scripts
[Music]
yeah so a huge I mean a huge fraction
this is establishing the workflow so
that data can be standardized and put in
you know and put in scientific archives
a lot of this I have this somewhere a
lot of these many many packages that we
create are ways of interacting with and
manipulating data and extracting data
from what are sort of the constellation
of scientific archives so you have the
very general ones like CERN makes it
runs a general European scientific data
archive there's Dryad which is the one
that the NSF tends to sponsor here but
then you have ones that are you know
there's a scientific archive for
parasitology right where people are
putting data about where and what
parasites are found in what animals and
you know like there are thousands of
people that use that and now a large
fraction of those can use this client to
pull that data and compare it across
lots of different research groups in
lots of different studies and so
facilitating that type of open data
sharing and the type of sort of macro
analysis that can be done when people
are sharing data in that way is sort of
our central goal at our open SCI and
this process is what is evolved out of
that central goal because we realized we
needed contributors from all of these
different fields because we weren't
going to be able to do that all
ourselves we needed those people who are
working and had that field specific
knowledge to contribute this these type
of specialty components we also have a
bunch of other much more general
architecture part of our team maintains
the are windows build in general and a
lot of the because so much of this has
to do with communication across
different archives and communication
between groups a number of the low level
Web API construction related packages
are built and maintained
our group as well any other questions
yeah I mean the biggest thing they need
to right now our reviewers and also
advocates to get the word out you know
is basically they met that it was
initiated Sipe I last year it was
announced it's I pi this year and like
this is sort of the second thing and so
we've had six packages go through but if
you go to PI open side org they have a
contact setup and they will add you to
their list of reviewers and generally
ask what your interests and expertise
are and then when something comes along
that is related to the type of work that
you do be it because you've worked in
that field or like okay well this is a
package that you know is using a certain
type of object-oriented structure which
you used in your work then you'll be
tapped for review but it's a very early
stage organization so actually there's a
lot of other you know you know the like
you know website creation and workflow
automation and all of those things are
just getting off the ground too so
that's just PI open side org yes
so one of the things that happens with
stuff that come into our ecosystem is
that we take on some of the maintenance
burden essentially I mean it's shared
with the author you know we sort of
think of ourselves as the maintainer of
last resort but we're on a whole lot of
nightly continuous integration tests and
compatibility tests to you know to see
if things are breaking with version
changes and such and if something is
breaking we can alert the author and if
the author isn't responsive we can fix
things ourselves we've done a lot of a
number of times what we've done is that
something that people use has fallen out
of maintenance because the author is
busy they've moved to new work they've
been doing open source and we find a new
maintainer for it so we have a pretty
big community of people who have been
reviewers an office a lot of experience
and so that you know long-term
reproducibility ZAR one of our central
goals and so that a lot of the argue
abuse standards are about making sure
things are maintainable and so that they
have the testing in the structure so
that other people can take them up and
then that's a process that we facilitate
ourselves we will occasionally do a
review after like a major refactor and a
new version change or something like
that as well yeah any other questions
all right well thank you very much
you